whilst everybody was having their
orgies free love sex they would no
longer be permitted to
enjoy the sex for each other they had to
fantasize that they were actually having
sex with jesus
um men included
[Music]
the cult started
like most cults in
the late 60s huntington beach was dark
you know this the same era as lots of
other cults
happening at the same at that time um it
was it was the movement of the 60s
and then what was the cult called it was
called the children of god then
the founder was
david brownberg
he and his children and his family
had
seen an opportunity for the
um what he called the lost youths
in the late 60s
and
it exploded and they had a what they
called a ranch much like
charles manson had a ranch
and they would sort of
replicate army style
training
into doctrines that he was still
developing the cult leader was still
developing
and it was born out of um
free love um
so goddess love love is sex um
and and the concept was
you know one big family uh creating a
sense of unity and belonging and it was
an apocalyptic cult so that the
messaging
was about
um that we are in the last days
um of the world
and uh the modus operandi the mission
statement was to prepare to warn people
about the the you know the antichrist
coming in to prepare their souls for
um
for you know the the great tribulation
that was to come
my father um had left the french navy my
mother had
left home in london
to paris at the right young age of 19
to become an au pair so both my parents
were young they were vulnerable they
were lonely
they were looking for somewhere to
belong they were searching in their
lives suddenly they had this
uh warm
welcoming family that just scooped them
up and their life was taken over and and
they had a sense of meaning and purpose
so that is the
the the sort of the cannon fodder
of of uh cult leaders they they prey on
very vulnerable people
my my parents joined in the late 70s i
was born in 79
so
exactly 10 years the call had been going
on for exactly 10 years
um
when i was born so at this point you're
in the uk yes we're in the uk we're
living in scotland we lived in
communes
modeled after the boots
the whole lifestyle that sort of sense
of community
and
the the locations of which were kept
secret
it was still a highly patriarchal
society
um
believing the bible is literal
they believed burke to be the prophet
the last prophet
so he wouldn't reinterpret
or expand on things
and that would be what they call the new
wine it was like equivalent to being the
the new new testament
to
help you
see it in that way
so
every year on his birthday was like a a
celebration
we would do fasting there would be some
new doctrine that he would come up with
and some of it was absolutely outrageous
so
they came up with this doctrine which
was basically
whilst everybody was having their
orgies free love sex they would no
longer be permitted to
enjoy sex for each other they had to
fantasize that they were actually having
sex with jesus
um men included
berg would
effectively get drunk and claim that he
was prophesying it was his way of
hearing connecting with god but he was
he was actually just a drunk
so when when berg writes mo letter about
um
how children should have sex
suddenly that's
something that we're being taught to do
um
a cult that practices and teaches
free love
regardless of age
will certainly attract
people that have a proclivity towards
underage sex
we you so you were subjected to sexual
abuse yourself yes so um
[Music]
i was eight years old when i was taught
to do an erotic dance which was filmed
with two other girls
one was five and the other one was three
and it was filmed and sent to berg
and then i had to perform it for the
whole commune
you were exposed to it i was actually
taught how to have sex i was
set up for date nights
at a very young age um
notwithstanding i i suffered quite a lot
of sexual abuse of from adult men
the person who is abusing me and several
other
girls in the commune
one night i
kind of
became aware that he was molesting
my sister and
i
i i distracted him
so that he would stop molesting her
and molest me instead
[Music]
you know you need to think
of it like
a domestically violent relationship that
kind of toxic
bond
uh restriction
of
uh the leaders would keep your passport
for example
um
you know you had to relinquish all your
personal goods to the greater the
commune
um
so it's it you know it's it's quite
severe entrapment
when you're going through
that much abuse you feel in your gut
it's wrong
you know it's wrong
you feel the resistance to it
you know the punishment the
constant
coercive control
the
the my mother's second husband
uh was
extremely
violent
he was
um
also also to my mother
as well
i am
you know it's important
that people understand that
a lot of the women even though they
joined
they were they were vulnerable
um
so even if my mother wanted to leave
there would there just be no way for her
to leave
we spent we spent quality time with our
parents one hour a day
and one day a week
and
i guess the more children my mom had the
further
apart our relationship seemed
so in essence
you kind of parented yourself
so my younger siblings do see me as the
their kind of real parent
and i was effectively a second mom
[Music]
and i yeah i cared for them a lot i
looked after them a lot i learned how to
cook and just try to you know i know it
sounds really stupid but in that really
restricted
life
you know learning how to make an apple
crumble or cake
was a big deal just to make their lives
a little bit better or
i would i would spend hours making games
for them coming you know just trying to
invent
games for them there's a very special
relationship between me and my siblings
and there's a lot of love between us
we've also lost
siblings
and that makes you even even tighter
yeah i think our our relationship is our
our center of gravity
can you remember the first time of
hearing something that you're not meant
to hear this from the system um we
didn't watch tv we didn't listen to
music we didn't read magazines we had no
exposure to the outside world in any way
shape or form
except for witnessing
recruiting or fundraising
so all
reading material on listening material
was
their
um
propaganda
i think it must have been like in the in
when we first moved in and
um somebody just hidden it away
so there were three books there was the
count of monte cristo there was three
musketeers and there was tale of two
cities and i completely and utterly fell
in love with the count of monte cristo
and i read it
and then turned it over and started
reading again of course
some of the other kids found me and are
like come on you've been reading that
for so long give it over
but that that that book
his story of
his pursuit of justice
and waiting and biding his time
really made an impact on me
at what point did you think i'm oh i
don't want to be here anymore so i was
12 years old so we're singing some
song i'm i i don't even know if i
remember the song
but i just realized that i i don't
believe the words
and
i start
miming
and i'm looking around the room
and just looking at these faces and i
it's almost as if i'm not in the room
i'm like a fly on the wall watching
and
i turn over to my best buddy
and
she's not singing either and she has a
beautiful voice so like you would know
if she's not singing
and it's like this look of knowing
between us
and that was my first
like real act of defiance like i'm
i'm not doing this anymore
i don't want to be here
basically up until
up until i was 18 it was abiding my time
and waiting to become of age
so that i could do that does that make
sense so it's like being where you don't
want to be but you're you're stuck and
you're trapped so
you just
get through until
you can
shortly after my 18th birthday i
squirreled a little bit of money away
just enough for a ticket
and jumped on a bus at 5am in the
morning
back to london
and landed at my nan's house
and
um
asked her if she could take me in and
she said yes but you have to get a job
and i'm like what's that
what was the act of leaving more
difficult by the fact that your siblings
were still
in the cult yeah yeah it was and for a
long time i kept on
visiting them
so i always felt the need that i had to
check up on them and
keep an eye on them but then my mother
decided to take my younger siblings off
to india
i wasn't about to do that
so that and then i didn't i didn't see
them for five to ten years
um
that was that was really hard
i um felt powerless to protect them
but at the same time i was in my own
survival fog
trying to
you know make my way in this world
i think i i came to terms with
the fact that if i worked hard to set up
my life outside the cult that at least i
would be there for them when they wanted
to leave
and that was the best way i could serve
them
did they all eventually leave
yeah
one of my brothers ended up coming to
live with me
who uh
in the end died by suicide because he
couldn't
live with
the aftermath
of all the abuse that he suffered
what about your mom did she leave
my mom
has a different tier of membership now
she's
she doesn't live in a commune anymore
but she still
supports them and has their beliefs
there is love
but it's very complex it's filled also
with rage and anger
and frustration
um
and more and more were trying to talk to
her and explain to her
how her decisions or her lack of
decisions or her apathy
impacted our lives
and her lack of taking responsibility
for
my brother's
mental health
and the role that she played in him
deciding to take his life
i'm angry about that
what happened to the cult and what
happened to the cult leader
uh berg the cult leader
died
karen zerby his concubine and peter
kelly her concubine took over leadership
did your any of your abusers come to
justice
yes so um
you know bearing in mind we had also
been raised to believe that the
authorities were the enemy and they
couldn't be trusted
so um
taking a risk and
speaking to the
police was a declaration of war on the
cult and ultimately my relationship
with some of my family
but it was also
a necessary thing to do to
parent myself to protect myself to look
after myself because nobody else was
doing it
i had to start reconnecting with other
people who'd left
and
convincing them to also come forward and
corroborate my story
so that that was you know a 16
year long
journey to justice
the person that i brought to justice was
derek lincoln
and he was a cult leader he
he was called member
i needed the validation from the judge
to say
this is what this man cost you and in my
mind i had the amount of years that he
took for me
my life
and
that's what i got
the judge heard me
and
he
he set me free
how long was the mad sentence for
13 and a half years
when you heard the sentencing did you
feel a sense of relief
happiest day of my life
i'm
slowly coming to terms with people
knowing
about this part of my life
and i think
you know part of the teasing out of that
process is
to
help people understand and other
survivors understand that
while this happened to me
i'm not defined by it
i have completely rebuilt my life
through education i've carved out a
successful career
and
you know
that's a testament
to the resilience and
you know so there's there's much more to
me than just that childhood
in the hierarchy of things that you can
do to gain healing
justice is top of top of the list
it's the best possible outcome
i feel different i feel better
i feel
at peace in my soul
because of the nature of of childhood
abuse
the
abuser has power
with the silence
when you lift
the veil of silence
with that you lift the inappropriate
shame that the abuser puts on you
and
[Music]
he loses his power over you
[Music]
because i've been on
a flat my back for so long i had no neck
muscles
so i had to have a brace on and when
they hoisted me into the chair
i caught a glimpse of myself in the
mirror and i just burst out crying